so I was sure not nothing would come of
Yoda
and here's Yoda the wise who's to say so
who gave you that call actually George
George George
and the Pope George Lucas through his
producer asked Jim we were doing them up
in movie in Los Angeles Jim was
obviously too busy and knew he didn't he
couldn't quite do that he has an
incredible challenge but this one he
couldn't quite handle as much as I could
he felt and that's how it happened it
was through a support of Jim and then
then I started doing it so who you
invented the voice you don't didn't did
anyone tell you speak this way
how could anyone possibly tell you to
speak there was no I never spoke that
way but right you know why he says that
why he talks that way I have no idea
there's always a reason for something
that's I come to learn that as a
scientist yeah you know my view of it is
first of all it was uh Larry and George
you wrote it and I said hey you know
this is nice can I it was only they use
it halfway and I said can I do it all
the time is it yeah my the way I view it
is Yoda is this is where like adjectives
and nouns are switched in place I'm not
smart enough to know what magic is right
okay
the sentence is fully understandable but
clearly from another syntax yeah it's
because that's the way the original Jedi
spoke it was a very formal and elegant
language he is now seven hundred eight
hundred years old at that time and not
unlike the Native Americans trying to
keep their language alive he also is
trying to keep the formal Jedi language
alive while these Cerf kids are talking
their language right and so he feels a
tremendous responsibility just talk that
way even though nobody else talks that
way even though he could probably speak
the way everyone else be right but he is
he has the integrity he feels cultural
imperative yeah that's that's what I
believe well you don't believe it
because you did it so therefore it is
yeah yeah it's a
it gives him a dignity in a con and
integrity that's important to his
gravitas I mean I think first of all the
performance that Frank gives is
incredible and it's got you know because
he's right there actually puppeting the
character you know there's a real you
know humanity to the performance you
really connect with it and then you know
he starts out this small little creature
living on the in the bog you know and he
turns out to be this wise you know a you
know incredibly powerful creature that's
that contrast is so interesting and
funny and stays with you Charles you
where you come in I think we all want to
be Yoda we all somehow feel we are
inadequate perhaps a little ugly a
little short but within us we have the
power to move mountains with just our
mind
[Music]